hallo mein name ist luca herzlich
willkommen zu einem blitz games spiel
lautet game of pitches episode one als
was zum heiligen stick als opfer von
zwei teile geben wird wir klicken
einfach mal auf play und werden
wir laufen auf was auch immer das ist
und wenn wir runter fallen sind wir das
ist ein glitch games definitiv also wir
starten und diese komischen blöcke
fliegen in alle möglichen richtungen und
wer wird was ist das hier kommen katzen
aus einem was auch immer das sein soll
denke mal das soll ein schornstein
darstellen und dass da oben weiß ich
tatsächlich nicht genau sieht aus wie
ein minecraft sei mit viel fantasie die
können noch schneller laufen und wir
können auch springen und da hinten ist
auch etwas aber ich weiß nicht was genau
ich gucken ob wir diesen blöcken hier
irgendwie interagieren können wenn ich
die online gottes funktioniert kann ich
hier in die tür rein ob body state of
the city dobler irgendwas ich was ist
das quest altem okay wenn ich dass ich
meine ich habe ja nicht mehr hinten ton
ich habe wahrscheinlich gegen den buckel
runter gelegt und den autobahnen quest
altem was sind das denn hier für leute
habe ich dem jetztigen wie weh getan
das hier ist irgendwie so eine kleine
raum abgrenzung ich weiß nicht hier
jetzt auch noch eine tür wenn ich hier
durch gehe dann bin auf mein gott man
kannte ich stecke fest ich versuche mal
irgendwie hier hoch zu kommen um zu
schauen ob hier oben vielleicht
irgendwelche antworten für mein co ich
bin wieder komplett unten bevor ich die
treppe dort hoch laufe schaue ich mal
einfach hier vorne weil hier auch noch
nicht oben mein gott was ist das denn
das roomers bmtv riesen reid okay der
ruhm is empty und das gibt es gibt wohl
auch ein grund dafür aber ich weiß
gerade nicht ich sehe hier keinen grund
ich versuche jetzt einfach noch mal hier
hoch zu springen damit die mir irgendwie
zeigen können wo ich antworten bekomme
warum das spiel so kann ich an der ich
glaube ich kann an der wand lang laufen
ich meine ich frage mich bei diesem
spiel auch gar nicht mehr das spiel
heißt game of glitches und ich verdammte
scheiße da oben geht es einfach nicht
weiter hoch wo soll ich denn hin ich
kann tatsächlich hier am rand langlaufen
und kann
ich weiß aber nicht ob das gewollt es
ich kann hier aus herumlaufen und jetzt
bin ich auf der rückseite von dem ganzen
jetzt eine treppe ich schaue einfach mal
ob die mich irgendwohin führen kann
essen-west item die man die scheiße ist
auch es gibt keinen checkpoints ich
behandle dieses spiel schon als erste
richtige spieler das ist ein fucking
glitch games ist normale fresse rotter
[ __ ] aber es ist in ordnung dann hoffe
ich einfach nochmal die ganze treppe
hoch ich meine es ist ja nicht so dass
es mich vorhin schon eine minute
gekostet hätte was wieso wo besteht der
sinn darin dass sich quest items
einsammeln und an das nächste quests dem
einsammeln will und einfach durch den
verfügten boden durchfalle on line 8
ich versuche mich jetzt einfach noch mal
in diesem jump'n'run hier weil das
vorhin hat mir irgendwie komplett hat
mich ab jetzt fall ich hier nochmal
runter okay ich bin jetzt hier jetzt
springe ich hier auf dem blog drauf und
jetzt waterfall way you lie wurden jump
that was zur heiligen scheiße da geht es
noch höher oder was also weit heißt
lehrer aber ich weiß jetzt nicht ob ich
jetzt wirklich in die leere springen
soll alter es kann ja nicht sein dieses
schild sagt mit to get the other side of
the jump and the bold und dieses schild
sagt johann tschopp
fakt ist ich werde ich muss doch
irgendwie da hochkommen oder bzw erst
mal dieses komische item dahinten
kriegen ich springe man nochmal hier
hinten hin um zu schauen dass ich dieses
item dahin noch mal bekomme jetzt gehe
ich definitiv nicht hier hin
das habe ich schon gelernt nur ich weiß
auch nicht wo ich jetzt stattdessen
linien soll ich meine ich muss irgendwie
auf diese komischen balken da kommt man
nach oben ist eine riesige tür alter da
will ich einfach hin dass jetzt einfach
ein fucking leerer raum aber ich habe
auch keine ahnung wieso der leer ist
oder ob ich hier irgendwie hochkomme
oder was passiert denn was ist mit
diesen blöcken ja eigentlich ich meine
diese blöcke kann ich hin und her
schieben aber ich habe jetzt keine
ahnung was sie mir bringen sollen wenn
ich den blog mehr als brückenbauer dann
ok tschüss blog ich meine ich kann die
blöcke nicht anfassen das spiel hat
keine steuerung ich weiß nicht wie ich
die aufeinanderstapeln soll ich glaube
ich bin aber auf einem guten weg die
irgendwie beieinander zu packen weil
wenn ich springe dann gehen die blogger
auch mal kurz mit hoch aber das ist
alles bisher nur ich will einfach da wo
meine freunde ich bin so nah es ist
wirklich so dass es mit diesen beiden
blöcken ihn wie klappt das man so ein
buch bekommen wenn man die beiden
übereinander packt ich habe keine ahnung
wie das geklappt hat vom schon jungs
müssen das nur noch mal hinkriegen mit
diesem komischen buchner das kann doch
nicht so schwer gewesen sein schweizer
mein gott ich bin oben ok und jetzt was
war das jetzt müssen jetzt nicht
irgendwas passieren von wegen du kannst
jetzt hier überlaufen
ich glaube ich kann es darüber laufen ok
stehe jetzt irgendwie hier in der luft
ich versuche jetzt einfach mal hier
drauf zu springen jetzt hier drauf jetzt
hier drauf und das wird auf jeden fall
noch ein langes jump'n'run
2000 jahre später man denkt sich auch
bei jedem fucking sprung also ich hab
keinen bock mehr